hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the influence of particle size
and associated sedimentary processes on
wetland gain and loss in the Mississippi
River Delta I am a trainer of beckman
coulter and i will be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
sponsored by beckman coulter we are a
leader in laboratory instrumentation
globally before we start there's a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers welcome to you can all
give this by hitting the green Q&A
button on the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions will try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
if we don't have time today if you want
a better look at the slides you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear see this presentation properly
please let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button will make sure to resolve
any issues now let's get ready now let's
get right to today's presentation we're
proud to present dr. Alexander Coker
from Louisiana universities marine
consortium dr. koker received his BS at
UC Santa Cruz a master's and PhD in
marine and atmospheric science State
University of New York stony brook then
he served on Tulane research faculty
member and accepted a permanent position
at region and marine consortium she
still teaches at Tulane and he's put
together a really exciting to talk for
us today so I'm going to turn it right
over to dr. koker and i'll return at the
end to take a Q&A Matt thanks so thanks
so much for that introduction i'm
looking forward to to this talk i hope
that you guys find this interesting i'll
be talking about wet processes regarding
wetland law
and wetland gain in coastal Louisiana
it's a intellectually fascinating
process and it's also one that is uh
that has a lot of very important applied
implications if we go to the go to the
first slide what you can see by what
I've got here is the Mississippi River
Delta from space and this is this is the
area that I will mostly be talking about
the Delta the mississippi river deltas
sits at the mouth of north america's
largest river and it was built roughly
speaking over the over the last five
thousand five to seven thousand years as
sediments from the river were deposited
in the in the coastal zone you can see a
few salient features of the Delta that I
might other system that i might point
out so for example we've got the ragatha
mississippi river right here which is
the main stem of the mississippi river
you can see the the city of New Orleans
the city of New Orleans would be located
right here you can see the mouth of the
Mississippi River which is marked as the
bird's foot Delta and you can see the
the wax life in the Atchafalaya River
Delta one thing that's another feature
that you can see is between and
Mississippi written between you can see
the the old loads of Mississippi River
and I'll point out in just a second the
rivers which is course every roughly
speaking every thousand years and you
can see the old river courses of the
Mississippi River so for example this
right here is my you love food which was
La Fouche is French for the fork I was a
fork off of Mississippi River and this
was actually the main course of the
mississippi river until about five
hundred 500 years ago you can see other
by use for example this would be bayou
teche switch with about 2,000 years ago
of course in the mississippi river
between that we've got large inner
distributary bay let's say for example
terrebonne bay
and better Terry obey right here another
interesting feature about the system is
that the river foot for the most part no
longer flows through its Delta there are
a series of levees along the Mississippi
River and that largely prevents Overland
flow the only places where the river
actually reaches the ocean are at the
mouth of the river by the birds for
Delta as the amount of the wax lake and
the Atchafalaya River Delta and
periodically we're going to flood
control structure called the Bonnet
Carre spillway is open so why why should
we care about the system why it's a it's
an interesting it's a beautiful system
but are there are there other reasons
why we should care about this system and
the answer is yes and that's in large
part it's economically one of the most
important parts one of the most
important coastal areas in the United
States reports of New Orleans in south
Louisiana account for something like 150
billion dollars a year in commerce
Louisiana Gulf Coast accounts for about
a third of the nation's oil
infrastructure about a third of the
nation sea food production it's it is
beautiful and ecologically important
it's home to numerous migratory
waterfowl and other and other
ecologically important species and it's
home to over 1 million people including
some of the nation's most unique
cultures like I said the system was
formed over the over the last thousand
years and the short story of how this
system is built is that when the river
is close to an area it brings in
sediments and fresh water and when that
material gets deposited in in the
coastal zone and then eventually the
system will upgrade it will build up and
will become so I that the channel
configuration becomes unstable and the
channel switches switches elsewhere this
is basically how the how the landscape
was born and it is you know one of the
sedimentary features of the earth today
on the monitor and so you can see each
nuff each number here corresponds to a
different a different time lobe of the
of T of the Mississippi Delta salvation
it's also it's also a really really big
system so we've got here just the
average discharge of the Mississippi
River compared to other distributaries
and other systems that people might have
heard from so what on average the
lowermost Mississippi built delivers
something on the order of seventeen
thousand cubic meters per second if you
compared access systems that people
might be familiar with like the Potomac
and the Hudson it absolutely dwarfs it I
got here a few systems that you might
not have heard of just called up so for
example baptise Collette right here I
only put that in there that this is one
of the offshoots of the Mississippi
River near as a bird's foot I put that
in there because it's a system that most
of you have probably not ever heard of
and you can see that it is substantially
larger than system that I would have
expected you to hear of like the Potomac
and the Hudson and the Colorado so a
very very large system on average if you
look at it during during flood it is
completely dwarfed system so if you're
thinking about things like particle
transport sediment transport etc you
have to be thinking about the the floral
water and the volume of water in the
system and the capacity for this water
to remove sediment it is quite
substantial the other thing that I think
that is important about the system is
that the area has lost a tremendous
amount of land it's lost something on
the order of 1,900 square miles about
4,500 square kilometers over the past
century people often talk about that in
terms of a football field per hour or
football field or per unit time it's
really remarkable it's enough land that
if all that land loss was concentrated
in the state of Delaware we
have 49 states in the u.s. grander than
50 so it's really really quite
substantial and given the importance of
the Delta to the rest of the United
States to look important to the Delta to
the aggressive and I mistake in terms of
transportation and commerce and
infrastructure sea food production and
ecological value this land loss is not
trivial in it and it's not simply
academic it's it's a major issue of
practical importance why are we losing
land I think you many of you have
probably heard of this there are a lot
of reasons there's no single cause of
land loss and in fact some of these
things Oprah interact but i will show
you a little bit more about a few and a
little bit of research that we've done
on this topic one issue of land loss is
the the high rates one is the high rates
of subsidence so Louisiana's thinking
you probably heard of this new orleans
parts of New Orleans are below our below
sea level you've probably heard that
steward a variety of reasons largely the
probably the two big ones heat is
compacting so organic soils deep water
and compact also a lot of there's been a
lot of fluid withdrawal oil and gas
withdrawal and brown water withdrawal
another reason global sea level rise so
global sea levels are rising and the
global a of global sea level rise is
accelerating so that would be another
reason reduced sediment deposition is
one so there's levees along the lower
Mississippi River like I showed you
prevent sediment from entering the
Mississippi River dams along the upper
mississippi river prevent prevent some
of that sediment from the even reaching
the coastal zone there's been a lot of
canals constructed in the there's been a
lot of canals instructed in the region
or oil and gas activity and navigation
so that's a that's the cause of land
laws there's been a lot of hurricane
activity and there's been a lot of
eutrophication there's a lot of
nutrients ative an attitude system and
that changes the plant community
one interesting thing that is not a
major cause of land loss in the Lower
Mississippi River is is the loss of
sediment offshore for a long time people
may have heard this and it looked like
there was a lot of sediment being lost
offshore and indeed if you were to look
at a slide like this you might be might
might be forgiven for thinking that so
for example if you look at these areas
you can see major sediment plumes into
areas that are 20 meters deep or deeper
so one life you might think that a lot
of sediments being lost offshore it
turns out that that is actually not the
case it turns out that that is there is
some sediment lost offshore but if you
do a mass balance of the system only a
less than a third of the material that
passes by Baton Rouge is transported to
to Southwest pass which is which is this
one most of the sediment is either trap
in nearshore channel or in nearshore
distributaries or in the champion of
channels themselves on the channel
itself which is interesting because it
means that that material is around for
for coastal restoration and I'll talk
about that later we can look at and this
is a paper I was not directly part of
this paper but I think it really sets
the safe nicely and one can look at
issues like the total load and also the
sand load there's a lot of extra center
in this area in terms of what is the
difference between what fraction below
this sand and fine and I'll get into
this more later but they have different
properties of course sand is probably
better for building up a marsh and it
has lower compaction rates so it can
build up an area more rapidly fines on
the other hand typically are transported
further and can get into into into
wetland and Inter distributary sort of
backwater systems excuse me but isolated
systems more easily so knowing the
difference between santa santa load and
the philo is is of importance to coastal
restoration planning now one thing that
I'll point out this is some nice work
that
a little bit of work that we've done by
my student of mine law and land and she
was actually looking at at chemistry as
a control on particle size on on
deposited sediments and I'll just go
into this briefly but essentially she
she took certain sediment sheep
disaggregated some did not aggregate
others incubated some denying debate
others and what she found is that the if
you look at the the way a particle
behaves its effective size is actually
different from from the substantially
different from the disaggregated size
and then it has important practical
implications if you're thinking about
how these sediments might behave in the
postal zone the disaggregated size that
you might measure by let's say we're
moving organic and D flocculating
sediments is very different from the
size that from the way a particle might
behave in nature so we can actually look
at treated versus untreated sediment
this is we've got particle we've got
treated versus untreated sediments here
for example in this top in this top
sediment in freshwater sediments and you
can see with treating with treatment and
no treatment the actual particles on the
particle size of the sediments are
substantially different so as we're
begin to talk about how these systems
behave in nature we have to realize that
what you might measure in lab is
actually quite different from the way
the system might behave in nature um
I'll talk to you for a second about
wetland loss and a little bit of work
that I've done I'll just matter in terms
of the driver and wetland loss so we put
this in context in terms of Grand Isle
Galton looked and we looked effectively
at sea level change in galveston Grand
Isle and Pensacola these areas all have
long running time gauges so water level
gauges that have been running for the
last let's say 50 to 52 almost 100 years
more like 72 almost 100 years
and one thing that you can see is the
grant is that the rates of sea level
rise at these places in terms of
millimeters per year are substantially
different Grand Isle the rate of
relative sea-level Rises on the order of
9 millimeters a year at Pensacola it's
on the order of two and a half
millimeters a year at Galveston it's on
the order of six millimeters a year the
other thing you can see is there's a lot
of variability so the variability and
the variability in these systems is
often an order of magnitude greater than
the long-term trend so if we look at the
year-to-year variability just or the
variability from a few years to each
other but say a Grand Isle you can see
it's on the order of tens to hundreds of
millimeters where we work whereas the
long term variability is you know well
nine millimeters or so another thing
that's interesting about this
variability is that it's spatially
coherent so places like here where the
variability where the gauges overlap you
can see actually that the variability is
coherent between let's say two gauges
between for example engage in Pensacola
lemma Galveston gauge or the Pensacola
and the Grand Isle gauge so you can see
that there's facially coherent
variability if what one way that we can
get it what the variability is is that
we can do trend the variability we can
take the gauge at Grand Isle we can take
and we can d trend and look for years
when sea level is higher than normal and
sea level is lower than normal and we
can go where we can reconstruct use the
ncf end car lee analysis tool and
deconstruct sea level during gears when
sea level is higher than normal and low
cielo year when sea level is lower than
normal the short story is that what your
during years when sea level is higher
than normal we've got and we've got a
low pressure system that's typically
over the north typically over that this
our central Gulf of Mexico which directs
win on shore
and when sea levels lower than normal we
see the opposite we typically see a
high-pressure anomaly which directs
winds offshore suggesting that there's a
dynamic control on sea level change that
dynamic control is there's a dynamic
control and sea level change the short
story is because if we are correct in
assuming that this interannual
variability results for meteorological
factors then we can remove the
correlated interannual variability by
subtracting one gauge from another and
interestingly because Pensacola is
stable and Grand Isle and Galveston are
moving Pensacola turns out fits on
limestone Galveston and Grand Isle sit
on soft sentence largely uncontaminated
silts and Clay's with some with suck on
some sand on the top we can actually see
we can see we can subtract one the one
gauge from another and get it inferred
some science curve this is what our in
firms of science curve looks like four
pounds just focus on Galveston on Grand
Isle but we've got a period of slow sea
level rise followed by a period of
relatively rapid science followed by a
period of slow subsidence we can break
that sea level record into into we can
look at what the rates are for various
period and these are the rates here at
Grand Isle on the right so relatively
slow at the start from the period from
let's say 1947 in 1958 we've got three
millimeters a year a little over three
from nineteen fifty nine to nineteen
ninety nine we've got much higher sea
level rise and then from 1992 to the
present much slower we can break these
apart in just slightly into more detail
units and get more detailed rates if we
look at what the rates are if we another
way to look at this these rates is to
break them apart for
six year period why six years six years
is nice it removes most of the interne
and correlated in your annual
variability and then also helps correct
for an 18.6 year tidal cycle we can see
inferred subside in trades that go up
that accelerate at the from the 1940s in
the 1970s and then drop all this
interestingly is highly correlated with
the production of the history of oil
production in south Louisiana and so as
oil production rates are accelerated so
did subsidence rate as subside as oil
production rates go down so did subside
a scrape that suggests that fluid
withdrawal is a major control on on on
subsided so a very interesting surface
to subsurface connection and as we think
about issue like particle size we have
to think about what is the oil you know
oil geologist think about all of this
sister sex regularly but what are the
what are the reservoir characteristics
what are the sedimentary characteristics
of the material above how does how does
pulling out oil and gas change the
orientation of the particles and lead to
society so there is a very important
particle size control on this related to
the oil and gas control the fluid
withdrawal control that's also i would
say associated with record with problems
with lamp our land loss soul and we've
got here land loss in the Barataria Bay
said this is one of those large inner
distributary basin in black and its
correlation with subsidence in blue what
we said what we suggest here is that as
some science rates go up so did my
in-laws at subsided straights drops so
in land loss so fluid withdrawal is the
major control on subsided and
subsistence and major control on land
loss it's certainly not the only thing
there's also a lot as i said earlier a
lot of other issues canals that have
been constructed levee that have been
built but we would say subside in fact
says something of a master control that
lowers the resilience of wetland
and and thereby aggravates wetland loss
what do we do about this is it all is it
all a lost cause we are coming up on the
10th anniversary of Hurricane Katrina
and I think a lot of people are asking
where does Louisiana fan in the in the
area since Hurricane Katrina and one of
the one of the more interesting things
to happen in the state in the last 40 in
the last decade is the development of
very serious coastal restoration plan
and one of these one of the plans call
for a lot of things they call for
strengthening levees they call for
pumping sediment out of the Mississippi
River and directly building wetland and
they also call for partially diverting
the flow of the Mississippi River what
I've got here in black are all of the
areas where the Mississippi where the
where the state's master plan calls for
effectively cutting strategic holes in
the river levees and and letting it flow
something close to its natural course at
the beginning of this talk right at the
beginning of this talk I told you that
the whole area that all coastal
Louisiana was built by the river
depositing sediments in the coastal zone
if we return to this the idea is to do
something to do something similar to cut
provocas in the levees in strategic
locations and to allow the river to flow
something close to its natural course
and build Lance there's a big question
about whether or not this can be done
and how feasible it is and it it's a
fascinating scientific problem to work
on how much land can we build if you
look at strategies of restoration in if
you look at other promises that have
been cut they were cut in the river over
the last century you can see that these
provinces often build something on the
order of a few hundred square kilometers
north of land over a timescale of a less
than a century that's that's order of
magnitude the scale of the system that
were we're looking at
as a scientist we can study some of
these areas that are analogous to the
kind of river diversions that are
proposed by by the state and many
scientists and if you could if you can
look for example there's uh I'll just
point out a few there's the West Bay
diversion at the mouth of the
Mississippi River there's the knarr vent
and Davis pond diversion which are near
New Orleans those are relatively small
there's artificial features in the
bird's foot so if you look at if you
look for example at this area there's a
lot of and we'll zoom in closer to that
in just a few minutes there's a lot of
of if there's a lot of areas that are in
there that was active channels that are
analogous to the type to conversion like
settings so these diversions have
captured a lot of a lot of attention why
there and there are I would say a number
of trade-offs associated with them why
should we why should people put in build
build these and white and why might they
not the advantage of them they are
capable of transporting large quantities
of sediments to receiving basins so they
are an effective way to move to move
sediment they're effectively gravity-fed
and so the operational costs are
long-term much less than let's say
dedicated dredging and the continued
delivery of sediments allow for a long
sentiment delivery over long period of
time which has the ability to allow
marshes to keep pace with relative
sea-level rise so you are as sea level
rises for a marsh choose to persist in
the face of sea level rise new material
must always be deposited on that Marsh
surface and you have if you have an open
flow of water and sediment the marsh
will have an easier time keeping pace
with you arrive on the other hand there
are some other issues continental scale
sediment loads are probably for what
they used to be largely due to the
construction of dams in the Missouri
River Basin
another issue is that some local River
environments favor deposition where the
other phase were erosion so where do you
put the diversion or the diversion the
best part of the diversion in the river
to build the diversion the best spots on
land to build a diversion and also they
could lead to probably one of the most
significant concerns is that they could
lead to shoaling of a Mississippi River
so you could wind up it'll Dale and if
you were to divert water you would slow
down the flow of the water in the
Mississippi River and the material
particularly the heavy material the fans
and the light would settle out in the
river and you can get a fan bar for me
and that would be hazardous to
navigation so pluses and minuses it it's
an issue that has gotten a lot of a lot
of attention in the scientific community
and and the role of particle size is not
a trivial one these are papers from from
nature geoscience so one of the leading
journals in the field and people are
arguing about how much sand is in the
Mississippi River Delta and is there
enough sand to supply since apply to the
whole system this material what this
kind of paper was taken up actually by
the popular by the local press and so in
an academic journal but certainly with
interest beyond academia my view is that
and I side with the people that are a
little bit perhaps less optimistic and
saying that there's not a huge amount of
sand left in the entire system if you
look at San loads they total sediment
loads they've dropped off substantially
since the 1960s and it looks like sand
loads have dropped off dropped off as
well so but as the state moves forward
with restoration and it's so basically
the state's plan is a 50-year 50 billion
dollar plan there are very important
questions about fan in the system and
particle sizes is a is a non-trivial
question for form a I'll just show you a
little bit more about these kinds of
diversion typesetting then a little bit
of work that
my lab group has done in these areas so
i'll talk to you about west bay which is
an area over here on the west side of
the mississippi river and branch paths
and associated areas on the east side of
the mississippi river just to give you a
little bit of navigation this is the
mississippi river right here this year
is is Venice Louisiana right here then
it's this is as far south as you can
drive a car we often refer to this area
right here as head of passes if people
measure how far city is from the mouth
of the Mississippi River they typically
take this point right here as the mouth
of the Mississippi I'm I'm going to just
zoom into an area right around up right
around branch past where you can see
this and I'll show you the the the
capacity for for land buildings so this
is a these are aerial images this is
from 1998-2000 5 just take a look at at
this area these air this area in here
and also these areas here so take a look
at these areas and as we move forward
over time you can see the marshes are
filling in and expanding and these this
is effectively the process the same
process that the that the plant that
river the river diversion plans want to
take hold up so it's possible it
properly managed to build land over over
a short time scale we did some work
looking at one of these providers this
was work that was largely done by a
master student Chris Esposito that I had
the pleasure of working with um and I i
sat on his committee he did some work in
the in the branch pathway ransom some a
tcp data so
acoustic current Doppler profile to look
at flux and distal ossett ease and
discharge across the river interestingly
he found that you go from here to here
excuse me from me pull up the whiteboard
if you go from here to here to here so i
believe the last one was believed it was
he think it was this one was the last
two here is the last one and you look at
the velocities the flux dropped
substantially as you go down this this
channel so the flux drops from as you go
from by almost by almost an order of
magnitude from 2020 700 meters per
second to on the order of 260 250 meters
per second but the velocities the ninety
percent velocities basically don't
change look at the start of the system
that ninety percent velocity is
something on the order of one meter per
second one hundred and four centimeters
per second as you're down at the very
bottom you see the ninety percent
velocity at 110 meters per second so
perhaps since it's the flow is even
accelerating maybe slightly the
threshold force and transport is
something on the order of 20 centimeters
per second and so the interesting thing
one thing that's interesting about this
is that the system is capable of
transporting sand about 6 kilometers
inland has a lot of practical importance
as well as I'll talk to you in cuz I'll
tell you more in just a second like I
said these these Martians must keep pace
how much so margin must keep pace with
sea level rise this grass is just a just
to show you what the what the rates of
relative sea-level rise in the area are
their tremendous there on the order of a
few centimeters a year so just just to
briefly show you that what
we look at some of some of the
sedimentary features in in here so one
thing we've got I'll just show you if we
look first at this at this slide what
we've got is the amount of deposition
which chris just color coded in red is
no deposition green is uh two
centimeters worth of deposition and blue
is up to 3 centimeters worth of
deposition we measured sediment
deposition by looking at by using
beryllium 7 which is a naturally
occurring particle reactive radionuclide
that typically sticks to fine grain
sediments and what he what we found is
that on the outside is the sediment
deposition in many areas that was up to
3 centimeters worth of deposition with
the greatest amount of deposition
occurring on the outside of the bar
rather than on the inside of the bar so
that's one that's one finding he was
also able to look at the we were able to
look at the the properties of sediments
that were deposited so for example we
could look at we took a series of X
radiograph these X radiographs so x-ray
his x-rays are just like the energy
x-ray sediments just like you can x-ray
your bones if you x-ray the sediments
light passes x rays pass through the
dense sentiments but make their way
through x-rays are stopped by the dentin
sediments but they make your way through
the left end sediments so it's a way of
getting it at the density of the
sediment and we can relate these graph
these graphs of so we can look at the
density of the sediment and that's
typically controlled by particle size in
the amount of organic matter and we can
also look at particle size of various
sediments which we did with the latest
laser diffraction particle size analyzer
and we can see that the particle size of
sediments and this is going from c4 to c
to c 6 so this goes from here
to here to here and you can see a
finding of sediments as you go across
the bar so at the top of the bar at sea
floor we're looking at for the most part
fine to medium sands and as we move as
we move back on the backside of the bar
we're looking at silt sand at silts and
Clay's so this tells us something about
the the environment that what a
depositional setting might look like and
Chris was able to put this in the
context of a of a conceptual model of
land building and the idea is that as
flow increases so as the river rises
with for example of spring flood the the
river is right Rises you get sediment
that's deposited on the on the top of
the on the top of the bar the river then
as the river drops you've got to we've
got the system exposed and you get sands
and muds you get vegetation building and
you get sand in mods deposited and
preserve so ultimately what you see is
alternating patterns in the sedimentary
record is alternating pattern of sands
and muds in this in this bar environment
and we can use this kind of conceptual
model to help advance our understanding
of how these systems form and we want to
understand how these systems form this
is critical for for restoring them one
point one small point that I just
mentioned alluded to Chris was able to
show interestingly that sand was
transported quite far in the system
which you know is an important practical
implication because if you're interested
in restoring marshes you want using the
diversion you want that material to to
make it as far as possible and he was
showing able to show that sand was
transported much further than a simple
model might might might might lead you
to the suspect
I'll talk for then a second about West
Bay this is kind of an interesting
system it's a crevasse that can cut that
was cut in the levee of the Mississippi
River right here in about two thousand
two or 2003 with the hope of creating
about 50,000 acres of land over a period
of 40 years kind of an interesting
system so it was conceived of as an
uncontrolled River diversion with the
hope of creating about 40 square
kilometers over a 20-year period it was
opened in the fall 2003 to an additional
depth of about 5 5.6 meters with an
initial flow of about 500 meters per
second now the system is scoured it is
now down to a depth of we were out there
just a few weeks ago is now 90 feet deep
so almost odd almost 30 meters deep so
it's deep in substantially interestingly
there was a after the diversion was open
there was a lot of showing that was that
occurred in pilot town so on the
formation of a lot of sand bars here
this is of great practical importance
because this is the first anchorage for
shift of as they come out of the edit
for the thumb as they come out of the
ocean so the form a so is that it's a
safe harbor for ships so the formation
of sandbars here is is not trivial large
ships effectively need need the
Anchorage and so it arrest so the
interaction between restoration and
navigation is a concern for many there
was also there was a thesis that
concluded that looked at sediment
deposition in the area in 2007 and it
concluded that it would take about 15
years to build land in West Bay um we
started setting the system in 2009 and
we were just about to corroborate Anders
disc including regarding land formation
but events just as we were publishing
our paper changed our view I'll tell you
that in just a second this is we looked
at the system in 2009 we both
position rate with beryllium seven
beryllium is a naturally occurring
particle reactive radionuclide with a
half-life of about fifty three days the
dots are proportional to the amount of
sediment that was deposited previous 53
days and you can see this sediment
deposition pattern roughly aligned with
the pattern with us with the with images
of set and flow in the base in itself
and so the suggesting that there is a
strong River driven transport of
sediment in the system interestingly the
highest sediment deposition we've
actually found over here outside of the
quite far from the from the mouth of the
of the diversion which is up here we can
also look at we can also look at excuse
me about that we can also look at I'm
just going to go to go to this sly for
just a second we can look at the
particle size of the of the sediments
that were deposited or so they look at
the particle size of what was deposited
here and we do see our sand being
deposited closer to the diversion so
that needs das are proportional to
particle size so we see certainly more
coarse grain material closer to the
diversion and finer sediments on the
eastern the common more distal phalanx
so that does help us provide information
that can be that can be put into into
models it does look look like there's
some flow down the center of the bay so
we can get a sense of the of the
controls on the sedimentary properties
in the system we can take x-rays and of
these cores and we can we can again we
can actually can take longer pores and
we can take X radiographs of these cords
and we can look at week again we can use
this to look at the the kinds of
sediments that are deposited you can see
these bands
this is where this one worked out pretty
nicely but you can see if we look at
let's say poor poor 30 any of these
cores you can see patterns of
alternating dense and coarse material so
right alternating less intense and less
dense material so probably similar to
what Chris Esposito was seeing
alternating patterns of fine and fines
and coarse sediments in some cases you
can see old marshes so you can see on
dark areas like roots here and here and
you can even see see see biogenic
material like shells for example so we
can look at the history of these
environments and see that these have
been largely River done largely river
dominated environments for the last four
the fourth of recent history we can also
take sediment cores and look at the
geotechnical properties of these
material so we can look at the water
content organic huh loss on ignition
which is organic content shear strength
and grain size and we can see that these
properties are for the most part related
interestingly I'll point out maybe just
a little bit of a pointer will look at
here which is this area the relationship
between grain size and shear strength so
indicating a particle size is an
important control on shear strength
obviously if we're interested in
restoring a marsh we want stuff and
restoring an ecosystem for the most part
one wants sediments that are relatively
some relatively high shear spring
because the area is exposed to waves
storms hurricanes and one wants to build
a marsh out of the aura marsh or an
embankment out of the the most resistant
material and we see that there is a
relationship between shear strength
which is effectively resilience to
erosion particle size and to some extent
also some water and and organic matter
so interesting relationships here and
the kind of material that one needs to
to calibrate models to show you that
slide so i told you in 2009 2012 we were
just about to publish work we exactly
did publish work based on a 2009 survey
that showed that it would take about
fifteen fifty years to build land it
turns out that we were wrong as we were
writing the paper the 2011 one came
along and that flood deposited a lot of
sediment in the wedding West Bay
additionally there were a series of
artificial island that were placed here
so we've got here we've got the
diversion right here here we have a
series of artificial islands that were
placed in West Bay we suspect that these
artificial islands change the flow in
the bay and there and created a more
quiet and environment which allowed
sediments to be deposited you can see
that this Marsh right here it is mostly
it's relatively firm it's mostly sand so
material is relatively relatively hard
once the system becomes became vegetated
it became quite resilient to erosion so
are the kinds of processes as we work on
on studying these systems we want to
understand these processes we want to
understand one wants to understand how
you can get rapid land formation because
the area is in a race against time so
build it i'll just give you a few final
reflections building land and
mississippi river delta is really a it's
really balance between supply and demand
it's our balance between the finding
balance between the supply of sediment
in the mississippi river and the coastal
zone and the demand for sediment in the
wetland supply side issues govern the
flux of sediment tuna version structure
demand side issues govern the impacts of
diverting love and diverting water on
navigation demand side issues reflect
the need
and the receiving basins of subsidence
rates and the impact of diverted water
on ecosystem function wetland stability
ensuring sustainability and finally I
will talk a little bit about particle
size to understanding particle size is
not trivial it plays an important role
in understanding how these systems are
built and is therefore an issue of great
practical practical importance with that
I will just give some acknowledgments to
the many institutions that that played a
role and also to organizations that
played an important role in funding this
work colleagues collaborators and
students and and mostly I'll thank all
of you for for listening to this so with
that I think I can close now do you guys
have any any questions thank you very
much dr. Cole Carew is an excellent
presentation um for those that you have
questions there's a quick reminder you
can click the green button on the lower
left hand corner of your screen and type
in your questions and I will be able to
read them for dr. koker we'll get to as
many as we can um I have a few questions
for you to get short discussion started
dr. koker um yep you talked quite a bit
about a few different techniques
including X radiographs and particle
size analysis could you give us a brief
overview of some of the other important
technique in your lab and how they've
evolved over time you know since you go
get your voices them yeah so okay so
we've done so we use a number of
different techniques to look at UM to
look at sedimentary properties so one as
I mentioned is is X radiography so we've
got an extra and affordable ex
radiograph system that's a digital x-ray
it works under the same properties like
like x-raying your bone you if you x
rays are penetrate through material
based on the density of the material so
different sediments have different
densities and we can use that for
wonders
and deposited material another system
another tool that we use we use a lot of
naturally occurring radioactive topes so
there are isotopes that there's a small
background radiation background levels
of radiation in the environment and
there's effectively there's micro
differences in these in these levels of
radioactivity and we use that to
understand sedimentary property
particularly we are interested in
sediments that in Radio isotopes that
attach on to sediments and that is
generally fine-grained sediment so we're
looking at material radioisotopes log
beryllium then as a short half-life
about 53 days led to 10 min and a
half-life of 20 days 20 years and cesium
137 a bomb product that has a half-life
of 30 years all of these are good for
reconstructing the history of the
sedimentary environment and most and may
all for the most part prefer to attach
on to fine grain sediments so these
mature those methods work great in muddy
setting maybe not so well and let's say
like a beach or a barrier island kind of
setting other tools that we use we use a
laser diffraction particle size analyzer
so we've got a beckman coulter ls13 320
we've got one of those it that that's
very good for measuring particle sizes
of samples that have been collected so
in again roughly speaking on the order
of about you know clay de plata
sand-sized particles would you use that
for the record we also got will use in
the field we've sometimes deployed lift
lit which are laser in situ scanner
ometer those systems I didn't show you
too much in the data Chris use one a
little bit in his work from but they
it's a field deploy unit unit which
which you can use which will scatter
scatter light and the scanner a known
amount of light scattering is
proportional to the particle size so you
so that's an
way of looking at particle size we use
other more both techniques to look at
like sheer veins to look at sheer
strength buckle furnaces to combust
sediments and we also partner with a lot
of other my abs at you by the
geochemistry or that look at a
hydrodynamic so the the ABC peas were
work was done like for example Wi-Fi
chris's adviser rooms of physical
oceanographer wow so there's a quite an
array of tools that you bring to bear
it's very interesting from my
perspective since since beckman coulter
manufacturers such tools um we're
getting some questions in and I'd like
to read them first we have a question
from I'm willing to mispronounce the
name will Graham Lou pinup fetching from
Royal hoskin Inc excuse me if I butchers
your name ah he asks you dr. Cole car
I'm the slide of sheer strength related
function of grain size can you elaborate
on the one but the grain type your three
curves red black and red oh they're up
nice to have a question that's so the
the olives gimmick charge it is right on
the black the the black is the d15 the
red is the d-10 in the d90 okay thank
you very much uh we have another
question from blaze his old dr. koker
japanese studies that exist the track
sediment longshore transport from West
beta version to the Plaka means barrier
island chain community I am NOT I am NOT
looked at too much of the of what
happens offshore at the in the West Bay
Area one area that we have looked at
that I just for this time did not speak
about was offshore transport of sediment
from out of each atalaya river in the
2011 what so we did a lot of work with
me at the cemetery plume and where it
went how much sediment was transported
during the two
11 blood on the chapel is I and we we
did look at that that was a fascinating
flood it was one of the largest floods
in the last 40 years they opened up an
additional water control structure and
spent an enormous amount of water down
the Atchafalaya River and it pushed the
short story about that during that one
was that one did not neg near the 2011
flood was not not have any more sediment
Danny previous years but the sediment
transport was highly concentrated into
just a few months but and that forced
sediments are far far offshore so
basically is you had high basically you
got a bigger flood you had higher
velocities and you put a foot more
material offshore into into open water
the interesting thing in terms of a
contrast between those two systems the
Atchafalaya system all of that material
was deposited in a relatively shallow
shelf that was often left just a few
meters deep or at least a lot of it was
deposited a shallow shelf it was just a
few meters deep on the west on the
mississippi river side anything that
Layton would make it out to see would be
deposited in a system that was still is
substantially deeper so I have a related
question for my own interest have you
noticed any effect in the sedimentary
processes as a result of the BP oil
spill 2010 that is that's a great
question so there has been so and it's a
it's a potential as we were heavily
involved in the spill when it happened
and then after that I moved on to some
of the other restoration question but
until you could see different things in
different places so for example in some
mangroves that were heavily impacted by
the spittle in the very early stage we
could see a lot of erosion of tendency
to the roots is interesting the roots
stayed behind in one area where you can
see all the sediments have been washed
out in other areas that were hit by this
spill you could see you would form tall
car balls and tarmac so some marshes one
common feature that you would see is
you'd almost get like a little crust on
the surface of the marsh like a cross
that would be anywhere from a few
millimeters to a few inches thick in
places that were heavily impacted
there's also been talked about
accelerator rate of erosion of the marsh
where the in areas where with where
there was some the spill so they're
still evaluating all that it sounds like
yeah still evaluating that and yes and
them yes and there's you know those
there's an ongoing research effort a
large ongoing research effort to look at
some of these issues we yes so we were
that's the short story so I have another
question from audience from Westar of
open space consultants he wants to know
do the particles have a discernible
upstream issue your profile pointing to
a source location ah great great
question I have the answer is it would
probably it would theoretically guess
practically that's more that's
practically that's more difficult to to
say often the river is so heavily so
heavily mixed and so in many cases it's
so well mixed that it's pretty hard to
find to the 22 source material I took
fade away from that thinking that it
would be it would be a difficult thing
to do some some people do notice
particularly you can find intrusions of
the red river you can see that by color
people do see the Red River drains of
permian basin that's heavily got heavily
oxidized clays and so that material is
visually visually noticeable looking for
jus chemical weathering signals is um is
challenging in part because of the
physical heterogeneity in the
environment would I would suspect
would would make that would would make
finding a signal more more difficult and
I thought about doing that kind of study
and stayed away from it because I would
suspect it would be physically very
difficult to get a handle on
theoretically if there was something
that had a distinct to you chemical
signature might be maintained but
physically I would think that that could
get very heavily mixed and you might
have a hard time finding okay we're
getting close to our final time so I
have a time for about two more questions
um so then we want to submit them please
do we have one from Belize is old what
are the most common colonizing plants on
the newly forming Delta's have you
noticed succession of certain species on
these newly formed Elvis yeah that is uh
that is my student Allison means PhD
thesis so great question hopefully
hopefully he'll be done in a year or
more and more complete answer to that
but but there is there is a lot that's
not there is stuff it's known that is
often Phragmites depends on the
ecosystem but often Phragmites is an
early colonizing plant some of the other
colonizing plants often can be things
like sagittaria or or type of the
ecological succession one is an
interesting one because there's probably
a strong relationship between the
ecology and sedimentology the elevation
of the area determined it's flooding
frequency which determines the plane
community the plants plant important
role in trapping sediment on that
trapping that Senate trapping that
sediment then what plants are there
affects the amount the amount of
sediment wrapping which affects the
amount of sediment deposition which then
affects the vegetation that grows there
so there's a feedback it's fascinating
question and hopefully Alex will be done
with his PhD in in a year or so and
we'll have we'll have a
answer on that okay uh so we have
another question from Shay feeding Ling
Hamilton he made a lame Hamilton excuse
me you mentioned that the sediment
delivery has decreased historically by
one half as Masuka queries of built-up
sediments from the dance systems and
Mississippi River competence been
considered in providing the dedicated
source of sediments for wetland
restoration you know I think it depends
on Wes chhan um I mean I don't know what
I don't think it's ever been I don't I'm
just talking about my own personal
understanding I don't think it's ever
been seriously considered um I don't
know certainly people have thought about
it and said you know you will see bumper
stickers around and safely send us dirt
so I certainly one that people have
thought of house how you would how you
would manage that would become a
practice have some practical questions
and I don't think that those discussions
or have gone all that far it's certainly
something people have thought of but I
don't think it's been the planning has
been as as serious as some of the planes
for releases of a flood pulses in the
Colorado there's been a lot of
interesting work on you know on
artificial flood pulses in the Colorado
River and I don't think that the level
of planning for flood releases has
gotten come to that level for the
mississippi missouri river system okay
uh well i think we can do one more
question and it's from will them again
yeah what what would you mean by percent
loss on ignition great so that's a proxy
for organic content very simply you sick
the sediment in in a muffle furnace for
six hours and you combust it at 550
degrees C so and everything that burned
you assume is organic so it's a good
with
it's a nice simple way of getting at so
we've got an loi of 20 that means twenty
percent of the dry way to sample
combusted 550 °c and we assume that
that's pretty much that that level
you're built you're burning off pretty
much all the organic but not too much
else then we've done some testing to to
look at that but it's it's a it's a
proxy for organic content thank you very
much dr. koker for additional questions
it will be able to follow up the emails
if you have them please feel free to
email us or type them into the Q&A
button now I'd like to thank dr. koker
as well as a lab roots for helping us
organize this webinar and of course all
of our attendees were for some great
questions interaction as a reminder
today's webcast will be available for on
division viewing for six months from
today you'll receive an email from us
alerting you when it's available on
demand and post on Margaret's calm
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join today I want to
thank you very much for logging in in
participating in today's broadcast and
we hope to see you next time so have a
great day and thank you very much for
listening to our webinar and thank you
all for listening and thanks Matt and
all your co-workers for organizing this
thank you thank you